merci beaucoup c'est tout bonnement
incroyable merci l'académie pour cet
immense j'avais seulement 45 secondes 45
secondes de plus que john bolton au
sénat quand peut-être un film et puis
finalement les adultes feront juste
c'est pour eux quentin tarantino tu es
un réalisateur le cinéma serait bien
plus ennuyeux tu arrives à tirer la
quintessence des acteurs il faut
vraiment c'est vraiment formidable
vecteur léo moi je travaille avec moi
quand il veut formidable et pour tout le
reste de la distribution pour bob
richardson
merci il faut aussi remercier tous nos
amis cascadeur et toutes les équipes qui
ont travaillé un peu pris de court
j'aime pas trop regarder le passé mais
je me souviens que mes parents
m'emmenaient n'a réduit qui m'ont donné
ma première chance
il ya plein de gens formidables j'ai
rencontré au long de ma carrière c'est
grâce à eux que je suis ici aujourd'hui
voilà il était une fois au niveau
macky sall et aussi pour mes enfants qui
me suivent dans tous ce fait nous
adorent